you know what came to this video playing
Sir John and I am from Greece to 468
rated a new zone probably interplay my
trusted Rubenstein is a mesh kind of
line jack leading to two interesting
play at least let's see what setup he's
choosing probably just the main line
no quickie five yeah this is also a line
I forgot I forgot the details about that
d5 is probably playing before
yeah
maybe castle first I don't know he fiber
self is a rare line he can take twice on
before now but usually you get enough
compensation for that
hmm interesting
okay I need to take anyway yeah might
take snow I guess after see for Quincy
no no no just just just just just wait
c4 Knight c3 I've got I've got the God
ticket take a take on h7 amongst others
okay you'll get the form that still
should be okay for what and him he
really I cannot really retreat I mean
don't play a play d5 done okay so Prince
to know okay
probably I should first take or not take
first check the question is Bishop
purchase Bishop b2 on something else I
should I am sure the retreat the the
bishop first to D 3 and then we should
be to probably I should retreated first
I'm not entirely sure but I'm down on
the clock already
this is just a pseudo active move doing
nothing
I'm just starting to get the porn on c3m
Bishop cakes takes Queen takes and it's
a pawn for nothing
yeah this is I don't understand it to
page six this rupee eight mate okay so
if I just take c3 now at the end that's
Queen there's some Knight G form but
this is not working I've got yeah this
is not working at all I've got the Queen
g7 check check and how many points is
that two pawns on or can't check still I
need to be a bit careful because see
foursome is somewhat weak
should I go F form yeah f4 is good F was
a good news keeping the night out of
play so 95 first not was not possible
okay so what now
adrien g-force is a good plan getting
getting pieces active him taking a b7
also yeah let's push that quickly
so g5 if he wants to yeah I can I do
that
f5 f6 kills kills the night it probably
wants to sacrifice it or is there some
way to to even improve on that jackets
its yeah it's good enough really just a
piece I only hope that reduced number of
pawns doesn't become a problem
look h1 now this is hanging so probably
activate a yeah but at the end I've got
I've got 95 check with the fork
yep two pieces
yeah it's some night and Bishop always
honey but 40 seconds check
check
check-check
check check check check check time
warning
check check check check check check
check what the heck am I doing here five
seconds checkmate
alright 90 moves yeah if you don't have
so many pawns left it can can get tricky
yeah mostly he overlooked this Queen g7
Queen G second trick but I don't think
that this position is so grateful black
anyway but maybe 95 and I'm not I'm not
sure it's a it's not so easy but his
says call asking protection is simply is
simply bad with the lost H stomach on
and here I don't I don't know I mean how
does he how does he prevent me from
winning upon it's just just tricky
business
yeah and this is checked simply simply
not working alright thanks for watching